first Caitlin's taken no else
everybody's gonna realize sooner or
later that must be
I'm just a regular guy
this suit will only absorb one of Grey's
punches anything more than that you'll
be like a pinata
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new flash
trailer don't worry there's no breaks
between now and the finale but they're
doing a new person from the comic books
next week the new character they're
bringing on is called the Griffin his
name is Griffin gray in the comics he
was a friend of Bart Allen so they're
like a couple speedsters that they
haven't got to on the show yet when he
debuted in the comics he was just a
normal friend of Bart Allen's who got
powers during an accident someone
attacked the car dealership that he was
working at he got special powers and
then tried to use them to be a superhero
but it ended up getting twisted in the
side effect sounds a lot like what's
going on with velocity-9
the more he used his powers the faster
he aged so you can kind of see what's
going on in the trailer here he steals
Harrison wells he looks pretty young but
then by the end of the trailer as he
starts throwing stuff around with
super-strength he's super old so it was
kind of a tragic story in the comics
about how the friend of Bart Allen tried
to do all these superhero things but he
just couldn't get it right every time he
tried to save someone someone got hurt
or when he tried to take down a villain
the villain ended up dying so it was
always a really big mess in Jay Garrick
like the real Jay Garrick who was also a
part of that storyline just kept doing
that adult thing like when you mess up
and one of your parents is like okay you
don't have enough experience to do this
right you're not ready to be a hero
so this Griffin character just gets
madder and madder eventually he tries to
steal a bunch of equipment from STAR
Labs to try and reverse the aging
process so it's kind of like a mixture
of what's going on with zoom on the TV
show zoom gets powers tries to get
faster ends up harming himself and since
then has been forcing team flash to find
a way to heal him speaking of which we
see that he's stolen Caitlin now the
thing about that is that you kind of got
a hint as to what's going on in zooms
head at the end of last week's episode
when he was getting ready to kill
burying he lands like look if there's
any part of you that actually did care
about me please let Barry go he
hesitates and they gets really pissed
off after he kind of like comes back to
his senses steals Caitlin goes back to
earth-2 so there's still a little
confusion as to which version of hunter
zolomon was pretending to be Jay Garrick
like at some point it was this future
version who was just masquerading with
the blue lightning other times it was
the younger version of him with yellow
lightning so they haven't been really
clear about that but because it's the
same person just from different points
in the timeline if the earlier
I fell in love with Kaitlyn the older
version would feel it eventually so ever
you want to think about it I wouldn't
recommend trying to go too crazy on it
because it'll drive you nuts this older
version some little part of him actually
does care about Kaitlyn but he's still
really twisted so what I'm hoping with
this Kaitlyn storyline is that she won't
be the damsel in distress because that's
like the lamest storyline ever really
hoping that she finds a way to save
herself
he doesn't be a great injustice to that
character just to have her sit around
and wait for somebody else to save her
like oh I guess I'm not a brilliant
scientist I can't find my way out of
this but the other stuff in the trailer
is buried just getting used to not
having his powers like he's not fast
enough to save his coffee mug from
spilling on the ground smashing into a
million pieces he has to take the bus
all over town if you've ever had to use
public transit like a city bus then you
know how inconvenient that can be so
it's just all these things pouring salt
in his wound he lost his speed and on
top of that he has to endure all these
indignities like there's a super villain
but super strength that I have to take
down
sisqó actually enacted in that short
called The Chronicles of Sisko was
trying to beef his suit up that's going
to help him in this episode if you
imagine team flashes arrayed Barry is
kind of like the tank he can just soak
damaged because he heals so fast but
he's been weakened in the villains crit
rating is off the charts so during the
episode Barry can only soak one punch so
what I think is gonna end up happening
is is he will soak that one punch but
then he'll have to find some other way
out of it
he'll have to appeal to the humanity in
the griffon like look don't do this
you're a good person you don't want to
murder people Caitlin will probably try
to do the same thing with zoom but
probably not be quite as successful
usually when you look at the storylines
in the flash the little bad like this
Griffin character also informs the plot
line with the big bad the zoom character
so thematically a lot of the same things
that are going on with the flash and
Griffin here will also be going on with
Caitlin and zoom so just look out for
that so like if something happens with
Barry it also might serve as the
solution for what's going on with
Caitlin I know a lot of you have been
asking about the Kevin Smith episode
that's episode 21 so that's still a
couple weeks away but that's down the
road but they've been talking about the
synopsis girder from season 1 is coming
back remember that was the villain that
bullied Barry as a child it was when he
first learned to go supersonic it was
the first time he learned to do the
supersonic punch but I'm guessing
because he died in that episode
that it's gonna be earth to Gartner and
he'll just be running amok the synopsis
also reads that iris offers to serve as
bait for girder so she's gonna be a big
part of the plot
they'll probably some very iris moments
because in last week's episode they were
teasing that she was thinking about her
and Barry being together like thinking
about actually pursuing that so they'll
probably building towards that in the
finale so if you're big fan of Barry and
iris together they they might be in a
place closer to that towards the end of
the season remains to be seen how much
of an actual couple they're gonna be the
flash doesn't really hang its hat on
relationships in the way that arrow has
the last couple of years so it just to
be determined as to like how much they
lean into Barry and iris being together
because I know a lot of people want to
see Bart Allen on the TV show eventually
you can't really do that till Barry gets
together with iris because Bart Allen is
their grandson from the future so that's
still like a long ways off like we'll
get Wally West with speed force powers
way before we ever get Bart Allen and I
don't think we're gonna see Wally West
get speed force powers till season three
maybe they'll tease that in the season 2
finale because right now the whole
action with Wally is just integrating
him into the family like hey we just met
you let's get to know you a little bit
better wow you're an engineer you're
working with engines you really like
things that go fast so we're just like
slowly wading in to Wally's character
right now the flash has to get his
powers back and I know a lot of you are
like how many episodes is gonna be
before he's fast again because in the
flash-forward in era when we're at the
grave seat he has powers again it could
be at the end of this episode it could
be at the end of next week's episode but
I definitely think it's gonna happen in
the next couple of weeks
but it is gonna be a lot of fun and
they'll still have fun with Barry trying
to figure out how to live without powers
there'll be all kinds of funny moments
it's not gonna be a total downer but the
other big hype you guys may know Game of
Thrones is back tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll be
posting it after the episode airs
there's a game of Thrones giveaway
that's going on right now which actually
reminds me there's a flash giveaway
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner caleb gibbs you and a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details it's just a $20
Amazon gift card so new Game of Thrones
site I'll be posting updates on Twitter
and Facebook my facebook is just
emergency awesome and my twitter handle
is awesome emergency there are links for
that in the description so you can
follow me there for updates on when my
videos coming tonight if you guys
haven't seen it while you
way for me to post that video you can
click here for like a big Game of
Thrones Season 6 explainer for all the
stuff you need to know before episode 1
and you can click here for my zoom
explainer from last week's episode just
a little confusing about the difference
between Jay Garrick and hunter zolomon
so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you